what i'm really excited about is just
that scene where the five or six are
together presumably six are together
with each other and they're all just
interacting talking to each other and
then instead of the spider-man doing the
point meme the center sixes
yeah
where are you from
[Music]
spider warren time yeah spider warren is
saying that he knows the trailer date
for the second trailer and also there's
some leaked photos to talk about
apparently let's see what's going on
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today we actually have a lot of things
to talk about of course including
spiderman no way home when that second
trailer should be coming out we've also
had a pretty big leaked photo from
spider-man noway homecome out showing
the sinister six kind of showing us a
scene that is going to take place the
first one of course the big question
that everybody has been asking when are
we going to be getting that second
spider-man no way home trailer i knew as
soon as we got the first trailer
immediately after people were going to
be asking where's the second one because
i knew we weren't going to see any signs
of tobey maguire or andrew garfield in
the first trailer i'm actually very
surprised that they showed alfred
molina's doc ock and they showed a
pumpkin bomb this is so funny because
now there's so much hype for when the
second trailer is coming i mean how long
do you remember that hype train was
going for the first trailer right and
now i'm thinking if they don't show toby
and andrew or even properly allude to
them being in here i feel like that's
going to be the thing that starts
casting doubt that they're going to be
in this movie but we'll start to write
and it looks like we don't have to wait
that much longer as we have news that
the second trailer could be hitting in
november now this news is coming from
daniel rpk he posted this to twitter
yesterday and for those of you who don't
know daniel rpk he is very very accurate
with when we rely on him
his track record for when trailers for
movies are going to be released is
pretty spot on and he was pretty
accurate about the first trailer as well
so this is most likely when we are going
to be getting that second full official
trailer from sony for spider-man no way
home actually that makes a lot of sense
because this is not when a turtle's
coming out if eternal's coming out of
november then you can slap the trailer
on there
and that'd just be awesome make the hype
bigger everyone's going out to the
theaters gotta see the news fireman
trailer second trailer and if you have
something to toby and andrew in there oh
man that's gonna be something special
yeah
right out of it
now will it show the other two
spider-man that remains to be seen i
have heard that they are going to show
them in a trailer towards the latter
half of marketing for the film and that
could mean the official trailer that
could mean a third trailer but
considering the fact that they actually
did tease alfred molina's doc ock they
showed a pumpkin bomb they teased
electro the lizard sandman i'm going to
assume that they're really going to show
these characters they really tease them
we don't know you're talking about in
the official trailer how all of these
villains have made it into this universe
i wouldn't be surprised if they said oh
but something else also came some good
came and that good comes in the form of
two other spider-men i could definitely
write
perhaps a shot of like three different
spider webs shooting from a scene or
just a quick shot of the three
spider-man together if we honestly got
the meme of all three of them pointed
together and that's all we got in any
trailer leading up to the movie i would
be perfectly fine with that but it does
look like that trailer is going to be
coming in november so we don't have that
much longer to wait i think if they do
the meme it has to be reserved for the
movie i think if we do that in the
trailer it kind of underscores the
moment a little bit for the first time
you're gonna be seeing the three of them
together it'll be better reserved for
the actual film itself yeah that would
be the appropriate way to fan service
yeah put it in the actual film guys but
don't put it in the trailer it's gotta
be something badass in the trail but if
it is that way the trailer i'm gonna
equally love it just as much as i know
me now speaking of all of the villains
moving on to the next topic the sinister
six and a leaked photo that has been
going around now originally a while ago
i'm talking months ago there were some
photos going around of doc ock after
melinda's doc ock jimmy fox's electro
and willem dafoe's norman osborne now we
didn't really know the context of these
leaked photos before and many people
thought they were fake but as it turns
out they're true they're real photos but
again the context of them was not known
until now as it turns out it looks like
these old photos are from a scene of
where the villains are inside their
prison cells in the sanctum or wherever
dr strange is seemingly keeping them and
now we have a leaked photo that is
pre-cgi so pre-any visual effects done
to it that shows these villains in
prison cells in the sanctum and it
matches with the photos that we've had
in the past now i can't show this photo
because it's copyright and of course
there is always a chance so it's
authentic and it does match up with the
other photos that we've seen before and
i personally know that this scene is a
direct scene from spiderman no way home
i've done a couple of videos
let's look at the photo let's look at
the photo here i got a bunch of
instagram message requests i'm i'm sure
that whatever
all right shouts out to me yup actually
got a few but i'm gonna go with war hot
panda press that meant i don't
understand i'm sorry because like what
warren said to play it's safe if i show
it it's gonna be blurred
oh
interesting okay yeah looks like
huh i mean if it's on complete cgi that
would explain why it looks like a video
game cutscene just to cast a little bit
of doubt here though what you got here
is okay that's doc ock in the center
that's jamie foxx to the far right and
it looks like they're in their exact
positions as they were in those photos
that warren showed earlier in his video
sad man here and lizard who look like
action figures and they're like
perfectly placed in a way that looks
like there's no movement or any like
even mocap people involved here
something about that looks really fake
to me they just look like weird models
yeah there are ways to take the human
photos that were leaked and sort of
manipulated that's a cool photo you know
it flushes out what we've heard so far
so in that way it gets the anticipation
further bubbling i don't know if it's
real or not but i just love how much
they look like action figures
they look like collectibles sad man and
lizard whoever animated this is really
please receive
[ __ ]
let's continue the video this scene is a
direct scene from spider-man no way home
i've done a couple of videos in the past
talking about a plot leak that i've
heard has been confirmed to be true a
couple of insiders told me about this
plot leak they said that pretty much
everything in the plot leak is real and
this scene happens in that plot layer so
when are the photos gonna rip off of
this scene because i think i know what
it is popular scene something goes wrong
with the spell and they break reality
and bring five spider-man villains of
other dimensions to the mcu green goblin
from spider-man 1 doc ock from
spider-man 2 the sandman from spider-man
3 the lizard from the amazing spider-man
and electro from the amazing spider-man
2. norman osborne is talking to the
others asking what is the last thing
that they remember and they all say that
spider-man killed them with the
exception of sandman now here's where we
get the scene dr strange wants to take
them back to their original dimensions
but the villains fear that returning
would mean that they would return to the
exact same spot where they came from
meaning they would die and here's the
really important part norman osborne
manipulates peter into freeing them
making him feel guilty for their deaths
peter fights doctor strange and breaks
the key which is a cube which we have
seen in the trailer that held them
captive and the villains are now free so
what this tells us is that dr strange is
holding them in some type of prison he
has some sort of cells prison cells
magical cells whatever you want to call
it holding them there and that is the
new leaked photo going around right now
and again it does include the leaked
pictures that we have seen in the past
and the interesting thing is that it
does look like they're in the sanctum in
fact it looks like they're in the exact
same spot where doctor strange performs
the spell in the trailer now in the
trailer around doctor strange and peter
during that moment we can see that
everything is kind of broken down and
crumbles this could be clever editing
for the trailer perhaps everything is
fine but the sinister six breaking out
actually caused some havoc and
destruction and that's what leads to
some of this stuff falling apart now of
course it's always hard to tell with
marvel trailers because they do things
like this to throw us off wait a minute
though but all that things being broken
up are before he even casts the spell oh
well it's from the look of the trailer
got to see where he casts the spell what
he's saying like what if they they
plopped the characters into a sanctum
that looks like it's been destroyed but
really that destruction happens after
the spell and the sanctum when peter
goes to see him maybe doesn't look like
that
okay but the trailer footage that we're
getting of him casting the spell it's
already in ruins isn't it
yes
so why would that be fake i don't know
that's what i'm trying i don't know why
it would be
just to throw us further off because
maybe the villains breaking out will
destroy the sanctum or put it into that
place of uh shambles there is this one
spot here when peter is looking at him
that looks like it could be a holding
cell for someone um there's that little
uh yeah the side there behind the stone
that strange is casting on all right
maybe
we don't find out everything from the
trailer because they're kind of
secretive with it but i'm gonna say this
is what's happening and honestly that's
going to be a super awesome spider-man
scene all of these different villains
from different universes coming into our
main mcu but let me know what you think
about all of this in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof thank you warren
what i'm really excited about is just
that scene where the five or six are
together presumably six are together
with each other and they're all just
interacting talking to each other and
then instead of the spider-man doing the
point meme the cinder 6
where are you from
there's a different version of you in my
world oh no
all right guys so leave your thoughts
down below subscribe click that bell
thank you more for putting this together
we'll catch you guys soon